when fauci killed science that's the
focus
of tonight's angle
now during a global pandemic he's had
time to do
every podcast every live stream and
glitzy photo shoots all of them under
the sun yet
sadly america's doctor hasn't joined us
on the angle for
well over a year although this morning
i did have the feeling he was thinking
about us
if you are trying to do you know get at
me
as a public health official and a
scientist you're really attacking not
only dr anthony fauci you're attacking
science
and anybody that looks at what's going
on
clearly sees that you have to be asleep
not to see that that is what's going on
science and the truth are being attacked
wait a second is that the argument
his argument is essentially i'm sorry
i'm howling laughing at this
i am the science i am the truth
that's his response to his many critics
who themselves in most cases are
distinguished scientific
researchers or treating physicians they
actually treat covent patients
the man really does think he's some kind
of deity except
there was only one guy who had the
standing to say
i am the way the truth and the life
and he's found in like the book of john
chapter 14 verse 6
not on msnbc with chuck todd
of course fauci's pandemic preening is
just the latest in a long line of
outlandish deflections
in fact we've noticed this anytime he
faces legitimate questions about the
science behind his pronouncements
dr fauci shifts to his default mode
he kind of cavalierly brushes aside the
question
then implies his critics are politically
motivated
now when i questioned fauci back in
february of 2020 about china's lack of
transparency
he gave me answers that made no sense
unless of course he was interested in
covering up
for the ccp yet for the longest time
i think fauci was able to glide by with
very little pushback from his media
boosters who themselves
secretly hoped that covid would kill
trump's chances last november
but now fauci's act is wearing thin
and we see time and again that it was
he and his like-minded experts who were
routinely
acting against basic scientific norms
over the past 16 months the angle has
showcased some of the brightest minds in
science and medicine
who've weighed in with meticulous
precision on how best to balance
health concerns in the very serious that
were presented by this virus
against the broader economic educational
and social needs of our citizens
treating physicians told us about
effective ways to treat the virus early
and cheaply i think the safety
of this cocktail of both
hydroxychloroquine specifically
zithromax and zinc is very compelling
should reassure every american it's very
impressive
i think we need to give more
hydroxychloroquine earlier
to help the obese patients we have to
give that drug more
and earlier cheap generic
and around for what 70 years
hydroxychloroquine but fauci
and his friends at big pharma and the
media that have none of it
any and all of the randomized
placebo-controlled trials
which is the gold standard of
determining if something is effective
none of them had shown any efficacy of
hydroxychloroquine
the hydroxychloroquine doesn't work it
doesn't work as a prophylactic it
doesn't work as an early treatment it
doesn't work as a late treatment
hydroxychloroquine doesn't work and the
president just keeps coming back to it
well captain forehead was wrong along
with the rest the data just published by
dr steven smith and another
observational study released today
show that fauci's dissing of hydroxy
likely costs
countless lives here in the u.s
are we talking we could have saved ten
thousand lives no
more than that man a lot more a hundred
thousand
yeah i i you know i i hate to say things
like that
but yes then on
herd immunity fauci admitted to lying
about the threshold level
for political reasons he didn't want
people to forgo mitigation or the
vaccine
telling the new york times last december
when poll said only about
half of all americans would take a
vaccine
i was saying herd immunity would take 70
to 75 percent
then when newer surveys said 60 or more
would take it
i thought i could nudge this up a bit so
i went to 80 85. this is stunning
so mr science was not about science at
all it was about
nudging and on the issue of acquired or
natural immunity
it's what you get when you're exposed to
covid you produce t cells
antibodies you contract the virus well
fauci once again responds with
dismissiveness
vaccines are highly efficacious
they are better than the traditional
response you get from natural infection
oh my god wrong in fact a bombshell new
study from the cleveland clinic covering
over
52 000 employees is that good enough for
you anthony
blows up fauci's profoundly unscientific
claim
researchers found no difference in
reinfection rates between
unvaccinated people who previously
contracted covid
and those who have been vaccinated in
other words
it's medical malpractice to force
vaccines
on the tens of millions of americans
probably more than that who've
already gotten protective t cells b
cells or covid
antibodies again from previous exposure
infection
my friends this is immunology 101 you
learn this like in your first year in
college if you're pre-med
one study showed people infected by the
original sars virus just to remind you
of all this
they still have t-cell immunity 17 years
later that was the original sars
look if we had an independent and honest
media this new cleveland study
would be leading every nightly newscast
but like fauci
they've committed to the lie that every
american must be vaccinated or be made
into social pariahs
you can do what you want but it doesn't
mean you get to go on with your
pre-pandemic life if you're not willing
to carry your burden in society
i don't get why you would not take the
vaccine i don't understand the sort of
macho thing about
i'm not going to get the vaccine i want
you to be a patriot protect other people
i say we need to shun those that refuse
to get vaccinated
speaking of vaccines fauci's also
fighting the science
on kids vaccines and covet
we hope that as we approach the end of
this calendar year
we'll have enough information to
vaccinate children of any age
okay this is literally insane in
anti-science it'll help no one except
the pharma execs
sex who've already become billionaires
with all these mandates
we've vaccinated the vulnerable
population in the u.s we protected the
people who are most at risk from covid
children are not at risk from cove at
very substantial rates more children
died last year from the flu than covid
of course of all the egregious fouchy
unscientific
acts lockdowns were among the most
destructive
i would like to see a dramatic
diminution of the personal interaction
that we see
if you look at what happened in europe
when they shut down or locked down and
went to shelter in place
they really did it to the tune of about
95 plus percent of the country did that
we really functionally shut down only
about 50 percent
oh my god you checked out europe's
economy lately compared to ours
i honestly cannot believe how compliant
americans were for so long there was
literally zero science behind these
orders remember it was
14 days to slow the curve save the
hospitals that was all out the window
and i'm not even speaking about our
unconstitutional loss of personal
liberty
with little to no legislative oversight
fouchy though loved the way the blue
states handled things remember the cozy
relationship with the cuomos
it was less freedom for people but more
power for unelected bureaucrats like him
and now data from the oxford university
compiled by bloomberg in may
confirmed what we told you a year ago
that lockdowns made no sense
it found little correlation between the
severity of a nation's restrictions
and whether it managed to curb excess
fatalities again
death is the end point should be uh
serious illness for this virus of course
the same study did find a correlation
between
hard lockdowns and deep economic pain
which is what europe is facing
and we see the same dynamic here between
red states that never shut down or
reopen very early and blue states that
stayed closed jobs data from april shows
that
8 of the 10 states with the lowest
unemployment rates are led by
gop governors and 10 states with the
highest unemployment rates
have democrat governors naturally
and perhaps there's no issue more
revealing of the fouchy fraud
than the issue of face masks the filthy
chinese-made face coverings that litter
the streets and clog our gutters
were always about politics and never
about science
i wear it for the reason that i believe
it is effective i want to protect myself
and protect others and also because i
want to make it be a symbol for people
to see
so it's a costume first of all fauci
admitted in a newly released email in
february of 2020
that masks really aren't effective which
is correct and
confirmed by a huge study on masks and
influenza that the cdc had posted on its
own website
back in may of last year and another
recent study from the university of
louisville points out that mass
mandates and use are not associated with
slower state-level cova-19 spread
during covet 19 growth surges
but since democrats in the media threw
out science
and facts they threw it out long ago we
still get completely incoherent
in unscientific recommendations like
this one
from fauci's pals at the cdc athletic
activities should be done outdoors
when possible wear a mask outdoors when
in crowded settings or during close
contact vigorous activity
like playing sports
zero evidence of the virus spreading
efficiently outdoors
which we knew and told you a year ago
but the anti-scientists at the cdc and
anthony fauci simply will not let this
power go
there's too much political power at
stake
and speaking of power the entire field
the public health
has been sadly and i think for a long
long time
compromised if not forever by the
research dollars from
pharma and also the influence of the ccp
and that means fauci's still giving
china the benefit of the doubt on the
virus origins
notice how he starts this next little
sound bite with
most scientists i know most of the
scientists that i know feel that way
that the most likely origin is a natural
origin
from an animal reservoir to human
however
we have not ruled out the possibility
that there
could have been a leak from the lab of
them
working on the virus it could have been
that someone
was infected early on they brought them
into the lab and it came out of the lab
but it was already out in the community
march of last year 2020 they were saying
there was no possibility that it was uh
it came from a lab now they're like oh
well it could come from a lab
which is it does he think we're total
idiots or is this how he does
science rank speculation devoid of any
serious genomic analysis
that we've would come to expect of mr
people magazine and aviator sunglasses
i've said it before and i'll say it
again those emails
are to fouchy in 2021 what the blue
dress was to bill clinton
in 1998. at one point fauci may have
deserved to be called an esteemed
scientist but not now
he's a bureaucrat who pals around with
global elites when he should be
focused on the scientific process
it's long since past time for him to
turn in his lab coat
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else